[Music]
and welcome to hannah art tonight
we have breaking news on numerous big
stories new york governor cuomo
in big trouble after a bombshell new
report revealed that cuomo attempted to
cover up
the nursing home death toll related to
his disastrous covet 19 policy
some are now calling for cuomo to be
prosecuted for obstruction
even at fake news cnn's fake jake tapper
he's actually covering the scandal
tweeting today the story keeps getting
worse for andrew cuomo we're going to
update you with more on this developing
story tonight and we'll have the very
latest
from the multiple scandals now rocking
the anti-trump
lincoln project now in complete meltdown
mode megan mccain
wow unleashed brutal tweets tonight
one of their co-founders steve schmidt
just resigned in disgrace
but first the democrats snap impeachment
charade sham it just faced its day of
reckoning
finally the president's legal defense
team they completely
eviscerated all of the democrats
paper-thin
arguments all of which were as we told
you
unconstitutional none of which meet any
real legal standard that would ever hold
up in any court
no rules of evidence mattered in any way
shape manner or form
and then add to that they're editing
they're slicing they're dicing
and then purposely ignoring all damaging
exculpatory evidence and presided over
by a judge who already declared trump
guilty
wow this is the united states of america
that's a kangaroo court
the house managers were they were
eviscerated
on their argument over incitement their
favorite word
insurrection they were eviscerated on
their argument on the constitution
the president's defense team exposed the
manufactured evidence their selective
editing they also exposed the democrats
rampant hypocrisy
it was a humiliating total complete beat
down
now the defense team started the day by
showing how the impeachment
managers actually had to manipulate and
did manipulate
the president's january 6 remarks watch
for yourself
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down to the one you
want but i think right here we're going
to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
[Applause]
we have come to demand that congress
do the right thing and only count the
electors who have been lawfully
slated lawfully slated
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
now as you can see not only did the
democrats selectively edit the
president's speech they also manipulated
key evidence pieces of evidence and they
frequently relied on guess what well
their best friends sketchy news reports
and rumor
to make their case that would never fly
in any court of law take a look
according to those around him at the
time
reportedly responded trump reportedly
reports
across all major media outlets major
news networks
including fox news reported reported
reportedly summoned reportedly
reportedly not accidental
according to reports president trump was
reportedly who reportedly spoke to the
guard
it was widely reported media reports
according to reports
reported reportedly now this is why
as jonathan turley warned the country
you do not do
snap impeachments this is why you
actually need
real time that you got to take so you
can gather real
evidence so you can conduct thorough
investigations
you can allow due process and even oh
the thought of it
allow for a defense now the democrats
case rests on two
incredibly flawed and extremely weak
arguments
now the first that the president said
fight like hell
and those words are unacceptable and
they incited
an insurrection on january 6 from the
president's rally
but as the president's lawyers rightly
pointed out today
in what became a 10 minute straight
montage showing democrats themselves
frequently using
this phrase fight like hell or fight
fight fight
in front of their own supporters
hypocrisy
on display take a look we can whine
or we can fight back me i'm here to
fight that
i'm here to fight back but we are going
to make sure that this fight does not
end tonight
this is a fight
for our lives i will fight like hell
to fight back against anyone we need to
say loud and clear
that we are ready to fight it's a bare
knuckles fight
now they're going to have to actually
fight back
we will fight back we're not going to
just take this lined up i'm just going
to keep the fight up what we have to do
right now is fight as hard as we can
we have to rise up and and fight back
continue to fight fight this is going to
be a fight we'll also fight him and
challenge him in every way that we can
this is what is our fight right now
there's the fight there's the fight
there's the fight and then there's the
fight to defend and we just have to
fight
but this is a fight for our country
so based on the democrats definition all
of them
were inciting insurrection if that's
what you believe
every democrat would be guilty by their
own standard
what is their standard and what about
their violent rhetoric
does it count as incitement to
insurrection
as always on this show we'll let you
decide take a look
you know why there aren't uprisings all
over the country maybe there will be
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there is unrest in our
lives you've got to be ready to throw a
punch
you have to be ready to throw a punch
donald trump i think you need to go back
and
punch him in the face that i thought he
should have punched him in the face feel
like punching him
i'd like to take him behind the gym if i
were in high school we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym
and beat the hell out of him no i wish
you were in high school i could take him
behind the gym
i will go and take trump out tonight
take him out now when was the last time
an actor assassinated a president
they're still going to have to go out
and put a bullet in donald trump
anywhere i have thought an awful lot
about blowing up the white house please
get up in the face of some
congresspeople
people will do what they do i want to
tell you for such
i want to tell you kavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind
and you will pay the price
you will pay the price okay
as you all know now it wasn't just
democrats spewing violent rhetoric but
also
yep their pals their allies their press
officers in the media mob
2019 the washington post jennifer rubin
calling the republican party
calling for it to be burned to the
ground quote we have to level them
because
if there are survivors if there are
people who weather
this storm they will do it again after
years of this type of rhetoric
there was a wave of far left political
violence we all watched it with
sadness and horror all summer most
democrat
democrats media completely silent
in complete denial the silence was
deafening
the lack and dis discounting reality
right before their very eyes
one year of riots the democrats the
media mob
oh now finally they're telling you they
care about rioting
well we should all condemn this
shouldn't be political
all these riots or any violence wherever
it takes place
and yes every conservative condemned
what happened at the capitol
in fact in many cases yeah democrats
actually encouraging
this summer's riots watch for yourself
they're not going to stop and and
everyone beware this is just a snapshot
of some of the damage that people will
be waking up going up but believe it
and i'm proud of the protests
[Music]
there is damage everywhere you look
honestly it looks like a war zone
heartwarming to see so many people turn
out peacefully
they keep doing it day after day after
day
our country is a nation of protest the
patriots were protesters
saint john's church is on fire do you
think this is
even that that's a myth
i hope someone burns down your whole
precinct with all
and this summer the vice president of
the united states kamala harris even
promoted that
bail fund for rioters arrested so they
can
get back out and join their friends
again i guess could you imagine
if president trump ever did this senator
lindsey graham he raised this very
question
it's a powerful one earlier today take a
look
does a politician raising bail for
rioters
encourage more rioting
council has five minutes
yes
if donald trump incited violence and
insurrection then so did pretty much
every democrat
in this country especially vice
president harris
and if the democratic managers if they
applied their same standard to kamala
harris
and other democrats they should all be
impeached and they should all be tried
including joe biden the guy that wants
to take trump to the back of the gym
then president and beat the hell out of
the president of the united
states is that not incitement to
insurrection
now so are there claims about the
president's rhetoric the same thing
now they want you to believe that his
statements about election irregularities
and voter fraud that it caused the
violence on january 6. you know and he
said many of you will
will march to the capitol peacefully and
patriotically so your voices can be
heard
but if that's the case oh we're going to
these democrats are they going to be
impeached
are we going to put them john thune
senator thune you want to put them
on trial should they be censored too
take a look
if stacey abrams doesn't win in georgia
they stole it it's clear
it's clear and i would say i say that
publicly it's clear
you can run the best campaign you can
even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
votes remain to be counted there are
voices that were waiting to be heard
and i will not concede respect and i
respect where you're coming from and i
respect the the issues that you're
raising you're not answering the
question
do you think you know you're not using
the word legitimate
there are still legitimate concerns over
the
integrity of our elections and of
ensuring
the principle of one person one vote
today's presentation was so compelling
so damning
that democrats were then forced to turn
to their favorite smear
they accused the president's legal team
of racism and sexism
yep take a look the defense counsels
put a lot of videos out in their um
in their defense playing clip after clip
of black women talking about fighting
for a cause or an
issue or a policy it was not lost on me
is so many of them were people of color
and women black women black women like
myself
who are sick and tired of being sick and
tired for our children
this summer things happened that were
violent
but there were also things that gave
some of us black women
great comfort often when democrats turn
to identity politics it kind of means
they lost the argument earlier today
here is what senator ron johnson had to
say take a look
i think the president's lawyers blew the
house manager case out of the water
they legally eviscerated them i think
their arguments
in when they showed the distortions of
the tweets
the selective editing showed the reason
why due process is important
and they certainly proved that the first
amendment
applies to political speech probably
more than anything
so again i think the president's lawyers
just blew
the house manager case out of the water
and as you can imagine
the media the mob was not taking today's
evisceration very well
in fact they were so upset by the facts
of the case amid a multitude of
complaints they decided
even attack yours truly how did my name
get brought up in this little
event while titillating and surely
satisfying to viewers of right-wing
media
none of it defended the tragic
consequence of donald trump's speech
i hope and trust you've never used the
word fight in a live report as you will
be part of the afternoon montage
this presentation was very partisan it
was a sean hannity mixtape
at that time almost literally what we
saw
to me was you know a preview
of hannity tonight and it
really did seem to be trying to just
make this
as much of a partisan process as
possible
those long video clips so many of them
we've seen on you know hannity and other
shows on fox
and the video presentation gratuitous
over the top
repetitive about democrats using the
word fight what was that meant to do
number one make the client happy the
truth
that they won't tell their audiences
today probably many of them
seeing the their own words in the media
and the democrats oh incitement to
insurrection
that's why this program is independent
this is why we don't rush to judgment
it's why we conduct our own
investigations and we provide
important context that's why we got it
right and they got it wrong on the
russia hoax
the duke lacrosse case uva kavanaugh
ferguson cambridge police
baltimore the covington high school kids
the media mob got it wrong again and
again
they rush to judgment they get it wrong
they do it every day
every time we were right they were wrong
every single time
and that's the same going for this snap
impeachment
ultimately this comes down to three
facts one the senate has no jurisdiction
over a private u.s citizen and cannot
remove president trump
from an office he does not hold two
according to the fbi the doj
court documents aoc and even the fake
news media outlets
the attack on january 6 was pre-planned
the president's
remarks therefore did not incite an
insurrection
that was planned ahead of time now did a
small percentage
maybe one percent of rally attendees
sadly participate
yep and they will all be held
accountable and
three if the words like fight like hell
and election challenges and now grounds
for impeachment
and the democratic party is in a lot of
trouble now soon the snap impeachment
shift shows charade will be over the
president will be acquitted
as he should be and in the coming months
democrats will be forced to answer for
their own
conduct in the height of a pandemic
millions out of work millions more
suffering
democrats chose a political show trial
as their number one priority
in the midterms i hope you remember that
you now need to know
this as well to quote raskin and
swalwell
and warren and pretty much every other
democrat and schumer and joe
and kamala and pelosi yeah fight like
hell
and as for the republican senators like
senator john thune reportedly open
to continuing this charade with a
censure of the former president
any republican that votes to keep
validating and legitimizing this
madness while never ever john thune
having the courage to ever apply these
exact same standards to your colleagues
on the democratic side you would need to
be primaried
and when did jon thune ever lift a
finger
to help expose the russia collusion hoax
i don't remember anyway any republican
if you're going to apply these standards
any more of this
to donald trump apply it to joe kamala
chuck
maxine waters nancy pelosi and every
other
insurrectionist violence inciting
democrat